Al
[Silence]
am
We are
continuing our journey through some of
the chapters
of authored
by it is an
incredibly an an Incredible Book of
of great esteem amongst the scholars of
Islam after it's after it was written
however he wrote this book from memory
while he was traveling and he said this
in the beginning of the book that what
he's about to write is from memory and
he's going through the difficulties of
travel while he is currently writing it
so two things that are mentioned with
regards to Z the first is that it is not
in strict order so some of its chapters
some of its
append some of its chapters some
of its
discussions and are in a place where you
would usually not look for
them if you are accustomed to the
traditional way that the scholars of
Islam wrote
and organize their books the second
thing is that because he wrote it from
memory and because it was this way there
are a few things that he didn't mention
but a lot of what he mentioned in is
taken
from
for so in order for us to kind of
compile all of those things so that we
can acquaint ourselves with the
prophet better sallallah Al wasam we
have gone to the original book which
is at the beginning and taken some of
the chapters from
[Silence]
therein
subh
[Silence]
waala we started
with discussing the
characteristics the physical
characteristics of the Prophet
Sall then we discussed his
character right then we discussed his
character now we are in a chapter
regarding his
miracles of course we cannot mention all
the Miracles of the prophet
sallam of course there are thousands of
them literally thousands of them
dispersed in hundreds if not more
different books of Hadith and so
forth and as a we
mention that they are too numerous to
number enumerate and number two they are
continuous some of these Miracles are
continuous for
instance any miraculous feat or
miraculous thing which occurs to any of
the followers of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that is
considered of his of his Miracles why
because this person is having this
miraculous thing occur for him because
of his
following of the Prophet Muhammad sallai
was so all of the miraculous things that
happened to his followers these are
considered miracles for him as
well and we mentioned many We are
continuing in this chapter and there
is a lot to go over
[Silence]
still
was
[Silence]
wasam
was
[Silence]
we see that the prophet sallallah
wasallam informed his
companions that one
day the riches the
Treasures of the Persian Empire will be
spent on the way of Allah by his
followers by the Muslims and this of
course was you know this is something
that is very outlandish if you imagine
the Persians at the time it's it
was an example a
parable it was something that they
would speak about as if it
is you know
extraordinary that they people would say
as rich as Persia the treasures of
Persia because of how wealthy they were
and how strong they were how
established and so to listen to
this from the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in a time of great
weakness where they were having trouble
fighting with quray they were having
trouble fighting with the Arab tribes
and yet he's saying this and making this
AUD audacious prediction or this
audacious prophecy it is something
that came to pass merely because he is
the messenger of
Allah and he does not speak from his own
self rather it is a revelation that
comes to him from Allah we see that
the prophet sallallah Al wasam in his
final years in Medina he began to invite
the Persians and the Romans and the
Ethiopians which were the three major
kingdoms we had as well
mik or
mikam he as well sent letters to
these different rulers inviting them
to
Islam and this is when the prophet
sallallah alaihi wasallam started to
wear a ring because it was his seal
right they would you know when he
started to write these letters
to the Persians to the Romans to the
Ethiopians to the
Arabs he was told that Kings do not
accept they do not
entertain letters that do not have a
seal they have to be sealed and so what
they would do is they would take the
letter they would fold it and on the
crease they would take wax and melt the
wax on it and then use the stamp to put
the impression onto that wax and now
it's impossible to open it to change it
to alter it to see what's in it without
disturbing the
wax this is a seal and so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam took a seal
that he wore as a ring in his final
years that said
Muhammad and he would use this as his
seal now when he
sent
his letters to Persia and he sent his
letter to Rome these letters were
received they were the same letter
essentially the same invitation but they
were received very
differently Persian
emperor made a mockery of it and he
ripped it up and disregarded it and the
prophet sallallahu alai am was informed
of his reaction and he made Dua that
Allah subhanahu waala do to his kingdom
what he did to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
letter and he prophesized that when the
Persian Throne Falls it will never be
reestablished in the Earth ever again
and that's exactly what came to pass and
by the time of om the Persians were
completely subdued and and their
kingdom was in collapse and one of
the
reasons that the kingdom was in such
shambles was because the Persians kept
killing each other it's true you know if
you research that time in history each
person that would get the throne would
only last a few days and they'd be
poisoned by the next person in line so
the father was poisoned then the son was
poisoned then brother was poisoned and
until they ran out of royal family and
they put the
daughter and this is when the prophet
Sall alai wasallam this happened during
his time there was no one left there
wasn't a single man left in the royal
family to take the throne and by the
time of Omar the Persians were
completely subdued they were living
under the rule of the successor of
the Prophet sallallah alaihi was
this is how he
received the prophet Sall alam's
invitation however K the Roman Emperor
he received this letter in a very
different
way he received this
letter and
he took this letter very seriously and
he respected this letter very much
had it read to him more than once he
looked at it he thought about it and
then he put it in a safe place for
safekeeping he declined to become Muslim
and many scholars of Islam many
historians and this is indicated
in many historians view that he did
become Muslim
that did accept Islam
but then when he suggested to his to
his Senate that he was to accept Islam
and what do you think if if we all
accept Islam there was an uproar it was
about to be a mutiny and so he decided
to leave Islam and continue upon the way
of Christianity
was prominent at that time and that was
the official religion of the emperor of
Rome and and his
Senate and so because he
respected the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
letter Allah subhanahu waala preserved
his Empire for a lot longer and he was
in power for a lot
longer and so when we hear that the
prophet s. wasam buari and Muslim he
tells His companion canons they're in
the middle of the desert in a dot in the
desert in a a mesjid that's walls are
made out of mud there's no ceiling for
the majority of the Masjid there's no
lights at night in the Masjid they're
going through times of extreme
difficulties and he under those
circumstances tells his
companions one day
soon this nation my nation will spend
the Treasures of Persia in the way of
Allah this is an incredibly audacious
prophecy and it's came to pass of
[Silence]
course
for
[Silence]
s
another
prophecy that the prophet sallallah Ali
wasam mentioned to his companions this
is collected by both bukari and
Muslim that he said it is
not poverty that I fear for you I'm not
afraid that you that my nation will be
in poverty and that this will continue
forever it
won't what I fear over my nation my
companions my is that soon the dun will
be open to
them soon the wealth will come in soon
The Prestige will come
the
power and the
authority these things will
come and I am afraid that when these
things come they will
change change the
hearts people who were devoutly
following the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam become
seduced by the riches and the authority
and the power and The
Prestige and so the prophet Sall Alam
tells us that this is the chief concern
he had he was not concerned that we
would
be a
poor Nation he was not concerned that we
would be a weak Nation he was not
concerned that we would
be a nation of
few rather he told us that this nation
will be the biggest Nation the greatest
nation most prestigious Nation most
knowledgeable Nation the most just
Nation however with authority and power
and wealth comes
seduction every person has to fight this
seduction and so this was eventually the
downfall of the Islamic empire right the
Islamic empire the Muslim empire this
Empire of faith will always continue
until the end of time it cannot be
eradicated from the earth as a matter of
fact this nation and this religion only
intensifies the more it is
challenged the more someone tries
to
eradicate the Muslims the more someone
tries to silence the Muslims the more
someone tries to stifle their progress
the more progress they will
have because the Prophet
s
said he said sallallah alai wasallam
that
Allah will always give Victory to this
religion even at the hands
of men who are not God-fearing men
who are Wicked
that even the wicked men when they wield
this book and this
religion they receive the authority and
the power and the prestige that comes
with raising the words of Allah
subhanahu wa taala the words of Allah
are
highest
right
[Silence]
s
and so this as well came to pass
[Silence]
the
Omar far
[Silence]
we see that another
prophecy that the prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam
prophesized was that the riches and the
treasures of Persia and Rome
will be allotted to the
Muslims his nation and this
happened in less than 10 years after his
passing I mean imagine that
imagine that in 23
years a man in the middle of the
desert with a kind of M crew of
different people you know people that
weren't considered to be of high
esteem with regards to their
wealth or with regards to their
accomplishments or with regards to their
lineage he had
servants
slaves
Drifters
foreigners these were the people that
became attracted to Islam and followed
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and these are always the followers of
the prophets in the
beginning and within 23 years that band
of
men conquers Persia or within 30 years
conquers Persia and Rome and becomes the
ultimate superpower consolidating all
known power at the time
that's almost unimaginable if it didn't
happen it would be hard to it would be
hard to imagine something that
happening and so when
people doubt the prophethood of
[Arabic recitation]
wasam Allah subhanahu teaches us in the
Quran
that if he was not a prophet Allah would
never give him this kind of
Victory Allah would never give him this
kind of prestige him and his nation and
his followers never he will die in shame
a person who claims to be a prophet and
is not a person who claims to receive
Revelation and does not this is
literally the worst of
mankind and these people have a very
special
punishment with Allah subhanahu
[Silence]
waala
for
[Silence]
well
sh
[Silence]
subh what had
subhah
waala
[Silence]
we see that this is a good
example and why this is a prophecy not
just that he informed
us that this would
happen but also that it came to happen
it came to
be if we look at false prophets
throughout
history Allah subhanahu wa taala tells
us in the Quran
often that how could we deny or
doubt the validity
of the Prophet Muhammad s. wasam and his
prophethood how could we doubt that when
we see the
results what are the
results that he is
given Victory he is made
victorious in battle and in
argument and his people are given the
Treasures of the
earth false prophets they don't have
this false prophets anything thing
that is
falsehood it starts out big and it grows
really fast and then it Fizzles
out why because Allah subhanahu waala
tells
[Silence]
us Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that the
truth falsehood can never stand up to to
tr to the
truth and that falsehood will start
out like
foam on top of boiling water and then it
will completely fizzle out very
quickly the opposite
of the
effects of the prophets on on people the
prophets and Messengers they start out
very humble very small to have followers
from here and there but these followers
are qualitative
followers and then the legacy of that
Prophet continues on for thousands of
years Muslim or not whether a person
believes in
as a prophet of Allah or not it is
institutionally memorized and preserved
in the minds of all of human beings
whether you're Christian or not whether
you're religious or not you know about
this man what could this man have
done to have his
name forever stamped in the in the minds
and hearts of humanity after him
these are not the effects of
wealth these are not the traces and
effects
of those who are false prophets cult
leaders they don't get this and a false
prophet essentially is a cult leader
it's what it
is and there are many false prophets
that have come none of them have history
Bend to their will and preserve their
name only Messengers only prophets and
Messengers
M the entire Earth was wiped out
for yet his name
remains and no different and even more
so our Prophet Muhammad Sall alaihi
wasam Allah subhanahu waala tells us in
the Quran that he will give Victory to
him he tells us that he will give him
Victory he tells us that he has given
him Victory it's he speaks about it
in past
tense Allah's already given him
that and this was speaking about
what when he migrated from Mecca to
Medina perhaps the weakest he's ever
been Allah
says
and then within 20 years 30 years
there's no one on the known Earth who
does not know the prophet Muhammad S.I
wasam and with time it only
increases that's
incredible the words of man do not do
that the words of human beings they
don't have that effect on the earth that
is something something that is
divine this is a person that comes
bearing the words of Allah the
Creator this is the kind of person who
has his name recorded and stamped
forever in the annals of History to the
point that even our calendars are based
on these men's
lives now Allah subhanahu waala tells us
in the Quran many
places that think about it if he was a
false prophet why does he keep being
given Victory by
Allah if your claim is that he is lying
and he's saying Allah said this and
Allah did not say
it he says Revelation comes to me and
Revelation does not come to him this is
the scum of humanity that would do
this if that is the case why does Allah
keep giving
him he wins the
battles his followers are incredibly
devout and that shows you the the
power of the message that he is
carrying that is that the message of the
Quran is so powerful so potent that it
drives men and women to memor memorize
it
verbatim and to teach all their kids to
memorize it verbatim to learn an entire
language just to read these
words the words of man they don't have
those effects on human beings not like
that and so Allah subhanahu waala draws
our attention to this over and over in
the Quran this is not
happenstance it is not
coincidence that he claimed
that Allah gives him Victory from above
his throne and victory is is constantly
had by him that's not by
accident that's an incredibly audacious
claim and Allah subhanahu waala tells us
in the Quran that if
he would have
added even a word or two into the
message that Allah entrusted him with
Allah would eradicate him from the earth
with
withness says this throughout the
Quran and
so if you look into the history of false
prophets and this is good we mentioned
this last
week we
mentioned the wisdom
behind for
instance or for
instance known as
or and all of them these different
people that came up in his time that
claim to be prophets and Messengers even
women some of
them why did
Allah allow these people to come up in
this
time in order for people to
see very clearly the difference between
a real prophet and a false
prophet these are false prophets they
start out with huge following they start
out everybody's around them and what
happens they swiftly are eradicated from
the
earth exactly opposite of the true
prophets and messengers of Allah
subhanahu wa
taala and so when we get that contrast
at the same
time and these were not weak or
feeble-minded men clever people M was
known for his for his eloquence and his
cleverness
and for instance
El
Ani he was known for his
strength and not only for his physical
and military strength but also he was
known to dabble in Magic he was known to
have a Jin that would speak for him and
sometimes even take over his muscles and
body to the point
that he suspected some of his
followers and so he wanted to show them
something and so he drew a line on the
ground in the
sand and he had a herd of camels tried
to cross that
line and he slaughtered every one of
them by hand without one even Crossing
this line it was an incredible thing of
strength and Valor and
courage terrified
them to the point that when he was
struck by the
sword his body sat up and started to
speak you know he was dead
already these are the kind of people
that claim to be prophets they were
people of High esteem in their
communities what did Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala do to them and what did he do
with the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam
very
different we will stop there
tonight
lb